the quickest way to go from $20 to$
10,000 is thrift stores and garage sales
genuinely because it's a place where you
can buy things for a quarter 50 cents in
a dollar and get 20 you can't do that in
many other places yeah but I feel like
if you're starting out at a thrift store
on Melrose no no way that's fouie thrift
store it's very interesting you can go
and purchase something for like 50 cents
a dollar and then you take it online and
you've got such an infinitely larger
audience and it's not even your audience
for was listening say I don't have an
audience no no no you just listed on
eBay you just listed on Poshmark marari
there's all these places now so the most
logical place I see is garage sales are
you still doing garage sailing to this
day yeah that's me like a couple weeks
ago honestly I like doing that more than
almost anything I do in life